[Music]
let's go to berta in monterey california
what's up berta
hi john how are you
nervous
oh don't be i'm terrible at this
we'll figure this out together no
worries at all i'm nervous too it's all
good okay
so um
first what is
what's your what's your full original
name is it berta
no it's roberta roberta
and then when did it switch from roberta
to my middle name is robert i thought we
were gonna have a moment here but you
screwed it up and started calling it
berta so
when did you switch to that name
um
well it's a family name so my grandma
was roberta and then everybody called
her roberta so everybody called me
little bert so it kind of always
yeah so is there an obligation that if
you ever have kids you got to name one
of them roberta
no
this stops with me good job
all right so what's up how can i help
okay so um i'm the oldest of five kids
and how old are you
i'm 27. okay
um
then my sister's 25 so we're pretty
close and then we have two they're
turning 18 this year
um and then the youngest is only six
years old she surprised everybody when
she showed up
um hello
turning six huh very cool so she has
like 11 parents right
pretty much yeah she does have a lot of
parents oh man okay so you gotta
you've got a hundred brothers and
sisters one of them is six all right yes
um well my one that's closest to me an
age um for a couple months she's been
like questioning
with me she's like
hey i think dad's talking to somebody um
who's not mom
what do you think and i'm like hey
that's not our situation
like dad's just super friendly with
everybody
um let's not push that don't read into
it too much because you're reading it
you're gonna find something
um
and then
my dad and the six-year-old were at my
house the other weekend
and the six-year-old brought me that
phone and says who's dad texting i love
you too
um
yeah
so
and what did you do
i looked at it and i told her oh it's
just a co-worker says like don't worry
about it it looks like they're joking
over something and she's like okay can i
play video games
so
i feel like she kind of brushed it off
but i mean if she brought it to me yeah
she didn't brush it off how many times
she brought this up
she's only brought it to me the one time
okay so just that one time
yeah they live six hours away from me
okay so
i have no idea what she's asking at home
gotcha
um
so when you saw that text
you're wise
you're an older sibling you've seen the
world
is it what you think it is
um it's definitely what i think it is
definitely what my other sister thinks
it is
so did you scroll up was there some more
shadiness
um i didn't scroll up i saw the message
it had lots of hearts and kissy faces
and stuff on it and i'm just like and i
just put it down i'm like i don't need
to see anymore yeah part of your soul
died so i was yeah that was my first
question i i do
i tell everybody i love them um i i've
got a core group of friends men and
women that i've had in my life for years
and years and years and it's important
to me
i've worked around
people tragedy so long that i want
everyone to know the last time i talked
to you i said i love you except for
james and kelly i never tell them that
um but
this is different clearly i don't put
smiley faces in hearts and kissy faces
after everything so um wow all right so
what's the next steps for you
um well i didn't want to
say anything in front of my little
sister because
she's
little so i waited until they had left
and i called my dad and i'm like hey
this isn't okay
um i kinsey is the one that found it the
baby's the one that found it um
so obviously
mom probably knows if kenzie knows
um maybe
maybe i don't know and he didn't really
say anything he kind of just listened to
me and then hung up the phone he's hung
up and i haven't
not really he's like okay
love you
bye
that's literally the strangest response
to getting busted i've ever heard
yeah
um
my dad is not good at confrontation in
words well clearly because hey dad i
just found evidence you're having an
affair all right see you later
wow
so
okay so how can i help
i'm just curious like
what
do i do if anything next because
i told him he needs to talk to mom and
he's like okay and then it just hasn't
like i've been getting texts for mom now
it just seemed fine like everything is
normal but i haven't heard from my dad
until like
two weeks
okay
i'm just curious like do i need to tell
mom
like i don't know like i if i was in
that situation i want somebody to tell
me yeah that's how i feel about it part
of me as you're saying this part of me
is like man this is not my circus and
part of it is no you brought this to my
house
and
you have put me in a position
where
either i have to
pull the pin on the grenade you put in
my living room or i have to lie and hold
secrets from my mom
and i my
initial default is i don't keep secrets
from my mom like that
and so what i would do is
get back in touch with dad
and shoot him a text and say we need to
talk today
and then ask him have you talked to mom
because i haven't heard anything
and say you've got 48 hours and then i'm
calling mom
yeah
the other part of it is he actually
called my other sister who like was
suspecting all this
and
like confessed to her and told her
instead of calling me back and saying
yeah yeah or anything and then he was
asking his mom knows and he kept
avoiding the question yeah of course no
i mean yeah
now he's put you and your sister in a
position to where
um i mean
i mean i don't want to talk bad about
your dad that's a pretty cowardly move
because he's basically made it y'all's
issue now
and
now y'all are quickly in danger of your
mom not trusting you and rightfully so
because y'all are holding stuff
yeah right
so yeah i would i would have
i would tell him you got 24 hours or 48
hours and then me and sister are calling
mom especially if he confessed
everything to your other sister have
everybody are y'all oh you're six hours
away so it'd have to be a phone call huh
yeah it'd have to be a phone call okay
um here's here's a couple things i would
have you and your sister think through
number one what's the purpose of this
phone call
because there's a strong possibility
that you call your mom and she's like i
know i've been dealing with this for 30
years this is none of your business
that's number one number two it could be
this
now you've put her in a position to
choose her kids or her husband
and that's messy
number three so you know what i'm saying
like so what is your purpose in this
and i would make the purpose if i'm you
the disclosure we're not gonna have
secrets like this inside this family
especially as we get up on the holidays
and
um
we're not gonna tell you what to do mom
if you tell us hey we're gonna i'm
forgiving dad it's it's been a whole
thing nobody knows what's going on
behind closed doors here i'm forgiving
him we're working on this together great
if you tell us we're burning the house
down and i'm gonna whatever i mean so i
think let her know that you will be in
support of whatever decisions she makes
and then you two have to decide what you
think of your old man
yeah
and you're gonna have to grieve that
because that's gonna that just sucks
yeah it does um does this surprise you
or no
um
not
not really he's never done anything like
that with
um
mom but technically me and my older
sister have a different mom and that's
how
they ended
but that was 15 years ago
so y'all you and your sister
he had y'all two with another mom and
then he cheated on that woman with your
mom with with
the new mom
no it was another woman in between
and
she's gone and then
we all really love the woman he's
married to now and she pretty much we
all call her mom we respect her as mom
do you hear the words you're saying when
i just said hey has this happened before
and you're like no but
uh yeah several times actually yeah yeah
yeah yeah this just sucks i'm sorry yeah
i'm sorry that this fell in your lap it
shouldn't have and it did and yeah
somebody's got to be the adult in the
situation and unfortunately it's not
your dad it's y'all
yeah and that i personally i'm not gonna
approach it from a gotcha or a can you
like an indignant rage
this is simply this came this is
happening
um mom and we're heartbroken and we're
not gonna keep secrets from one another
in this house
okay and there's a way that you can be
respectful and let everybody retain
their dignity
and
then you and your sister decide like
here's how we're gonna we're gonna talk
to dad we're not gonna talk to dad we're
going to
be honest with him about how much he
broke our hearts and he blew the family
up again
and and and or we're gonna say hey man
this is your life
i hate that you screwed everything up um
there's a six-year-old involved here
which is heartbreaking
there's a whole family involved here
this is a six-year-old living in this
crap you know what i mean
yeah that was yeah that was one of the
hardest things for me was
the little one yeah yeah yeah but it's
hard for you to let's be honest yeah
she's sick and but
don't don't collapse your pain too
because it's real but yeah i'd call them
and say you got 24 hours 48 hours to act
like a grown-up
after acting like a child for all these
years um or i'm calling mom and me and
sister como
and by the way call anyway
okay you know what i mean um she's gonna
need support and love and she's probably
thinking
oh gosh
these girls are going to side with dad
and what
it's if y'all love her and you respect
her and you're heartbroken with her i
think it's important to let her know
that y'all are standing by her side
okay ugh i'm so sorry berta that just
ugh breaks my heart man
and that poor six-year-old
geez
yeah berta one more thing that
six-year-old
she needs to know she did not break up
this family when those questions come
out over the next few years
because she'll start putting two and two
together that i picked up this phone and
i handed it to big sister and now
everything's a mess
she needs to know dad caused the mess
not her
that's gonna be a tough one to unwind
thanks for the call berta